Several American towns claim to be the
birthplace of the sundae.
Sundaes first appeared in the 1880s, when
the sale of ice cream sodas was banned on
Sundays. Instead, soda fountain operators
poured soda syrup on ice cream, added
toppings, and called this new treat the
sundae.
Today, ice cream sundaes come pre-made and
frozen in individual servings.
There's no need to wait.
This decadent dessert can be served up in an
instant.
At the Sunday Factory.
Production starts with something called the
White Base Mix.
It's a pasteurised blend of fresh cream,
milk and a variety of sweeteners.
A worker adds a blend of yellow coloring to
the white base mix, and this takes it from
bright white to an off white.
A generous helping of pure vanilla extract,
lends a distinctive flavor and adds extra
color to the cream base.
After a final stir, the mix is ready for a
freezing process, during which air will be
added to turn the mix into soft ice cream.
It's time to cue the containers.
Two at a time, individual size sundae cups
move forward on the production line.
They meet up with the ice cream dispenser.
It automatically pumps precise amounts of
the soft vanilla ice cream into the cups.
It fills the cups to the three quarters
mark, leaving plenty of room for toppings.
It's now time to prepare the next layer of
deliciousness the chocolate fudge sauce.
A worker mixes skim milk and sweeteners to a
frothy consistency, and then adds several
large bags of dark, rich cocoa.
The mixer paddle agitates the ingredients to
distribute the cocoa evenly throughout.
The chocolate fudge is pumped into a plastic
tote to cool overnight.
During cooling, the sauce thickens up
substantially.
It's now a rich chocolate fudge syrup.
Velvety smooth.
The chocolate syrup flows out of the tote
and into a big tank.
From there, nozzles dispense the chocolate
fudge syrup onto the vanilla ice cream in the
cups. Next, a worker pours a liquid topping
blend into a high speed mixer system that
beats it to a whipped consistency.
Nozzles deposit the whipped topping onto the
syrup covered ice cream.
Now it's time to add some chocolate crunch
to the smooth sweet sundae.
The system sprinkles semi-sweet chocolate
chunks onto the whipped topping.
It's the final touch.
These single serving chocolate sundaes have
been prepared almost entirely by machines.
A conveyor now sends them through an icy
blast of air for a quick freeze.
Exiting the freezer, the frozen sundaes
travel forward, shielded by overhead guards
for food safety reasons.
The sundaes funnel into a single file lane.
This positions them to receive lifts.
The lid, slide down a chute and land on top
of the ice cream sundae cups.
Rollers. Press the lids down on the rims.
A revolving apparatus deposits plastic
collars around the lids.
Moving forward.
The machinery sorts the sundae cups in rows
of two.
This allows a robot with suctioning arms to
pick up six at a time and pack them into a
cardboard box.
The boxes travel under and over packing tape
to seal the tops and bottoms.
Incredibly, this factory produces 1440 ice
cream sundae cups every 15 minutes.
And it's all thanks to the magic of
mechanization.
This company also produces tubs of flavored
ice cream, so there are many mouthwatering
choices to be made at dessert time.
It's a fruit known by many names cactus,
pear, cactus fruit, and prickly pear.
It grows on several species of cacti, which
are native to parts of North, central, and
South America.
Some growers, in addition to selling the
fruit, produce a puree which they sell as a
flavoring. Prickly pear martini, anyone?
Cactus pear fruit is high in fiber and rich
in vitamins and minerals.
It's sweet and delicious, eaten as is, or as
a natural flavoring in foods and beverages.
In the Salinas Valley in California, the
cactus pear harvest begins around late August
and continues through early April.
The fruit is ripe when its skin begins
turning red.
The harvesters wear thick leather gloves to
protect their hands from the thorns, and
safety glasses to shield their eyes from
loose thorns that blow through the air.
Tractors haul the cactus pears to the
processor plant.
The fruit first passes over brushes and into
a vacuum that removes loose dirt.
Then, through a shower of chlorinated water,
which kills off bacteria, the fruit enters a
cold air dryer for about five seconds, then
passes through a hot air dryer for 20s.
The fruit exits completely dry.
A quality control team removes any with
bruises or other cosmetic defects, and
transfers those cactus pears to the puree
line.
The fruit that passes inspection falls into
what's called a simulator, a machine that
lines them up in single file.
The simulator deposits each cactus pear into
a cup on a computer guided weigh and sort
machine, which classifies each fruit by
size, then applies the grower's price code
sticker. The fruit then travels on the
conveyor belt that leads to the padded tub
designated for its weight.
Classification in.
A worker stationed at the tub packs the
cactus pears into a lined shipping box.
Another worker removes any less than perfect
fruit that managed to slip through the
previous checks.
Those also go to the puree line.
On the pure line, the dumper drops the
cactus pears onto a conveyor belt system,
which transports them to the crusher.
The machine crushes the fruit, separating
the skins and flesh.
Mashing the flesh into puree and extracting
the sweet magenta colored juice.
From the crusher, the pressed skins drop
onto the vibrating shaker, while the puree
and juice flow through it into a tank below.
The shaker separates any puree still caught
in the skins.
The skins drop into a bin and are hauled off
to be used as compost or sold as animal feed.
Once the tank is filled to capacity with
about £400 of pure.
A pump transfers it to a large hopper.
A worker releases puree from the hopper to
the finisher.
The finishers find screens, trap the seeds
while letting the puree pass through to a
holding tank below.
The seeds are sold to businesses that
process them into oil for cosmetic and hair
products from the holding tank.
The Deseeded puree passes through a second
finisher with even finer filters.
Then it flows into a tank for
pasteurization, which kills off any remaining
bacteria. The puree is finally ready.
A worker fills a drum which is double lined
with plastic bags.
She draws for one cup samples from each drum
for quality control tracking.
Once a drum contains £400 of puree, the
worker zip ties each bag separately, closes
the drum with a lid, safety seals the lid
with a lock, then puts the drum in the
freezer. The cactus pear puree is sold
frozen to the food and beverage industry,
which uses it to flavor many products, from
ice cream, sorbet and gelato to flavored
water, wine, tequila and brandy.
Early versions of pancakes were thin like
crepes.
By the 1780s, American cooks were adding a
leavening agent for a fluffier, more filling
pancake. That's when pancakes transitioned
from side dish to main course for the first
meal of the day.
Call them hotcakes, griddle cakes,
flapjacks, or pancakes.
There's nothing like a heaping helping of
them splashed with syrup and with frozen
pancakes. Whipping some up for breakfast has
never been easier.
Pancake production starts off with the
leavening agent the baking powder.
They combine salt, whey, and various
flavorings in a big blender to create a dry
ingredient, pre-mix.
Since these will be buttermilk pancakes,
they add powdered buttermilk for flavor.
They pump liquid ingredients from storage
tanks into a huge blender.
These include water and eggs, sweet cream,
liquified sugar, and soybean oil.
They add the dry premix and flour until the
batter reaches the desired consistency.
An employee tests the batter's viscosity by
pouring some in a device with a little gate.
He opens the gate and measures the flow down
a ramp.
If it runs too thick or too thin, it won't
produce pancakes that are the desired
diameter and uniformity.
The pancake batter passes the viscosity
test.
They release the batter from the holding
tank and it flows into a depositor system.
The depositor has nine nozzles.
Each nozzle shoots an exact amount of the
pancake batter onto a hot moving griddle.
Because of the perfect viscosity, each
deposit of batter radiates out to form a neat
round shape.
Each one the same size as the next, about
ten centimeters in diameter.
They run three depositors in moving griddles
simultaneously to produce 750 pancakes a
minute. That's an incredible 45,000 pancakes
an hour.
After several seconds on the griddle, one
side is cooked so automated stainless steel
spatulas flip the pancakes over.
There are two sets of flippers.
After flipping, the first set repositions
and the second set flips the next row of
pancakes. It's mechanized synchronization.
The flippers are spaced apart exactly as the
depositors are.
So the pancakes arrive at the flippers in
the correct order to be picked up and turned
over. Once flipped, the pancakes continue
along the cooking conveyor and the other side
is cooked. It's a short ride for these
pancakes to be completely cooked.
From dollops of batter to uniformly rounded
and cooked pancakes.
This process has taken just 90s.
The pancakes somersault off the cooking
griddle and over a roller to land on the next
conveyor. This somersault exit has a
purpose.
It keeps the pancakes from folding over so
they land flat.
Hot off the Griddles the pancakes cool down
on the ride as all three production lines
merge and head into a freezer.
Inside the freezer.
It's a very frigid -28 Celsius and the
pancakes freeze fast.
Now it's over to the packaging line.
This is where the uniformity of these
pancakes pays off.
They're similar. Diameter means they can be
neatly packed in groups of six.
Machinery seals.
Two stacks of six frozen pancakes in one
wrapping.
It has taken less than five minutes to
prepare, freeze and package these pancakes at
home. Prep time in the microwave should be
mere seconds.
Just add syrup and this story has a sweet
ending.
Haggis is Scotland's national dish, made from
minced lamb and beef encased in beef
intestine. While quintessentially Scottish
historians believe haggis actually originated
in ancient Greece and eventually made its
way northward with the Romans to Britain.
Haggis is traditionally served with mashed
potatoes and turnips, with the Scots call
neeps and tatties, along with a glass of
Scotch whisky to wash it down.
At the haggis factory.
The production process begins with beef fat.
They put it through a mechanical chopper,
and a guillotine blade slices it up.
The chunks of fat go into a large cook tank.
They fill the tank with water and simmer the
fat for 2.5 hours.
Then, using a strainer, they drain the
cooked fat and put it in a tub.
Then they emptied the tub into a mincer.
Next they chop up lamb lungs.
Haggis recipes sometimes also use heart and
liver.
They simmer those in a cook tank as well for
2.5 hours.
Using a strainer, they drain and remove the
cooked, chopped lungs and transfer them to a
tub. They now take dried shredded onions and
rehydrate them with some stock from the
cooked meat. They pour the onion and stock
mix into the tub with the cooked lungs, then
empty the whole thing into the mincer to
join the ground fat.
Next to different grinds of oatmeal, medium
and coarse, to give the haggis just the right
texture. Not too stiff, but not too loose.
The consistency is key, which is why the
grind proportions are a closely guarded
company secret.
Also a top secret.
The composition of the spice blend.
They now add. All the company will divulge
about this seasoning is that it includes salt
and pepper. The oatmeal and spice blend.
Now join the other ingredients in the mincer.
And there you have it the finished haggis
mix ready to be stuffed into casings.
In keeping with tradition, the company
encases its haggis in beef intestines.
After a thorough cleaning, the intestines
are stored in salt before use.
They soak in cold water overnight to
desalinate.
This also softens them up until sufficiently
pliable for the stuffing process.
On the filling line, workers slip an
intestine over what's called the stuffing
horn. Then, with a knee, activate a lever
that triggers the machine to pump out a set
amount of haggis mix.
On this run, they're preparing the £1 size.
They closed the casing on either side with a
thick aluminum staple.
Now they spread the haggis out on cooking
trays and pierce each casing to let air
escape as the casing shrinks during cooking.
The temperature inside the steam oven is
230°F.
The haggis cooks for one hour, during which
the casing shrinks and forms into a ball
shape. Once the haggis come out of the oven
and cool workers cut them apart.
Each haggis goes into a printed plastic bag,
then into a vacuum sealer.
The machine draws out 99.9% of the air
before sealing the bag.
This vacuum packing process extends a 7 to
10 day shelf life to four weeks.
The packaged haggis now drop into a tank of
hot water.
The bags instantly shrink and thicken by
25%, making them significantly more durable.
Haggis may date back to ancient Greece, but
it certainly changed with the times.
This company also makes a one minute
microwavable version, a canapé format, and
even vegetarian haggis far beyond what
Robert Burns could ever have imagined.
And.